let's say someone's listening and they
go this Brian guy doesn't seem like my
bag don't take an ass full of steroids I
want to get myself to as healthy a level
of testosterone naturally using
lifestyle a diet and maybe non-clinical
supplementation as I can what's the
prescription this is not medical advice
oh my god dude that's so General I I
could what would you do if you were to
say I would be like what are the
principles that people have to follow I
would say getting to bed at the same
time every night ideally and waking up
at the same time every morning following
your circadian rhythm you know as it
starts to get dark you start to wind
down you get to bed at an adequate time
hopefully around you know
depending on what where you live your
schedule Etc but ideally no later than
like 11 or 12.
um getting up as the sun's coming up
it's not always going to be you know
perfect like that but I mean just
following your circadian rhythm in
general very very much aligns with the
diurnal Rhythm that your like pulsatile
secretion of hormones would follow and
when you start to manipulate that in
like a artificial way and trying to I
don't know putting yourself in
situations that are not conducive to
high quality sleep it's you know bright
outside you're trying to go to bed or
whatever you don't have blackout blinds
like there are ways to try and hack it
but at the end of the day I think that
even when I track my sleep metrics when
I go to bed at 10 pm versus 2 A.M like
it's a dramatic difference in terms of
quality I feel like in general and um
I don't think anyone actually has a full
clear answer on that by the way because
I've asked guys like huberman and stuff
about if I go to bed at 2AM but I sleep
eight hours and I have blackout blinds
and I optimize everything could I get
the same Health outcomes as if I was you
know a dialed in like 9 30 p.m sleep
what would be the difference between
that and just going to another time zone
basically the only thing you would maybe
do is restrict the amount of daylight on
the back end because obviously nighttime
is going to arrive sooner if you've got
up a little bit later so you're going to
restrict the amount of daylight that you
got but even if you could compensate
with that by going right okay I'm going
to over expose myself to sunlight during
the day or to Daylight then yeah that
would be interesting like your body's
pretty intuitive and oftentimes I think
it knows better than you do like when
people try and hack their body sometimes
they're fighting against something that
is not leading to an optimal outcome and
they could have otherwise just been
following the common principles of go to
bed at a good time after the sun goes
down get up at the same time every
morning sort of following you know the
normal circadian rhythm that a human
should follow
um I'm not saying you have to do it but
that's what I would generally recommend
okay that's sleep yeah sleep is sorted
what else is someone doing optimal
testosterone naturally a good proportion
of like not depriving yourself entirely
of fats in your diet because some people
will very much especially in the fitness
space will go protein carbs they very
much want to try and hit their body
weight in protein and then they'll have
carbs but then they will neglect fat
content which can be detrimental to
testosterone and that's often overlooked
even people are eating adequate calories
they are sometimes depriving themselves
of basic things like one Mac
micronutrient entirely or micronutrient
density like one of the things I do is I
plug my diet into this thing called
chronometer it's kind of like my fitness
pal but it's uh more comprehensive and
then it breaks down all of the
micronutrients and minerals of your
Foods so it shows what vitamins and
minerals you're deficient in of your
diet model and then you can then
backfill accordingly based on what
you're deficient in WoW so that is
typically what I would recommend too
because if you don't have the cofactors
and substrate to actually produce the
hormones even if you're eating
what you consider to be a good diet it
might be deficient in adequate zinc or
it might be deficient and adequate
bioavailable B vitamins or whatever like
it would be worthwhile to kind of at
least one time like flesh out if you
follow a consistent diet what does that
yield in terms of all of the vitamins
and minerals and is that satisfactory
for optimal hormone output and that's
where you can then determine like actual
targeted supplementation
because oftentimes people are blindly
taking [ __ ] like oh I think I need to
think so I'll just take this
compensating for malnutrition in one
form or another with supplementation if
you need to like I have obviously food
Whole Foods is in general I would say
going to be better but it depends
because some people don't want to eat
more some people have goals that are you
know body fat related and they want to
maybe even restrict calories and at that
point you might be cutting something out
that was hitting your micronutrient
allotment for some specific thing and
that's where you would then supplement
potential so there is a
like a tension between
calories calories in and the
micronutrients that you begin to cut
calories to the point where you can't
eat enough to be able to get the
micronutrients in depending on what your
goals are because again some people
don't care about getting you know as
lean as you for example come on uh okay
so we've got food we've got sleep
um what else what else is in there is
the big movers for testosterone
production
um I guess far as environmental
stressors and whatnot it's hard for me
to quantify like all the chlorine in
your [ __ ] shower is killing your test
like I don't know for sure but I would
probably Edge again if you've got a
special filter yeah sure do you yeah
what brand is it do you know
I don't know but you can just search
like chlorine filter shower head
chlorine filter or something or is this
um yeah probably like you could probably
vet out a good one within with a little
bit of research don't rely on me for
that I don't even know if mine's the
best one but I remember when I was
looking for it it seemed to be like I
would very much do a lot of the same
research as other people or thinking
like okay uh YouTube who who do I trust
in the industry that otherwise has made
videos on this content and is otherwise
already dissected the literature okay
does that guy know what he's talking
about okay let me cross-reference it
against a couple other people that I
trust and are educated boom and then you
kind of create a conclusive educated
guess as to what is the best do they
have monetary upside from promoting this
thing are they sponsored blah blah blah
go look at the Amazon reviews does it
look favorable you know obviously stuff
can be manipulated you can't ever fully
trust anything I guess but I mean you
gotta do you just do your due diligence
and try and do what you can what other
environmental factors apart from yeah
um
off the top of my head like I know uh I
don't know how impactful the receipts
thing is stop touching the seats son
that's what I'm telling you so that I
guess
um what else uh oh cooking in like like
plastics for I think is something that
could be impacted not cooking like
heating stuff up and like storing stuff
and Blasting drinking out of plastic
bottles not ideal yep okay we are
killing I'm traveling I would normally
have a glass bottle but uh uh yeah one
thing that I found is a really nice
solution for that
um a bunch of different companies make
glass Tupperware yeah plastic lid glass
uh sides which I'm gonna guess is mostly
okay because the food's not going to be
touching the top yeah all my prep meals
are in glass containers really nice
super easy to clean don't smell as much
uh if you do end up leaving it for a few
days you don't feel like oh God it's
infused into the Container now and I've
permanently got this sort of moldy
residue that's going to be in there yeah
um steel shakers yeah for uh using uh
protein and whatnot
probably some sort of cooler as well
would be steel I'd be interested to know
I'm gonna guess that Yeti and and
companies like that have done a good bit
of research into
um other metals leaking in at all is
there any any risk of that uh Ben
Greenfield was on the show and he was
telling me that uh xevia xevia is the
sweet drink right
um he had the one of the product
development managers at that place on
and they they used a special type of
aluminum that uh was leaking less
aluminum
aluminum and British son we actually
have an extra I was a double jerking I
know what you're talking about
come on now come on you're Canadian come
on do I say stuff weird sometimes
bits and pieces that's a boot apparently
do you are you very polite
I think yeah well I the one one of my
good friends uh Dr Steve McGill I landed
off a plane and the first thing he said
to me when I got to Canada was how are
you good he says and how have my
countrymen been to you have they been
polite and I was like is this are you is
this like a joke or is this real and
he's like and I was like yeah perfectly
black is a good good I got on with this
day so apparently um uh genetically
predisposed to being polite but uh yeah
the yeah sorry [ __ ] metal the metal
that's in the drink right the metal
that's in there's
xevia Khan is uh they've looked at
formulating that in different ways so
people are certainly coming around to it
but I was walking through Whole Foods
with a bunch of friends that are um big
into the health and fitness anti-seed
oil anti-estrogens and everything etc
etc and I was like uh what about that
can I have that and they're like no I
can't have that can't have that kind of
that it's like what about those candles
over there and they said no full of
estrogens can't have that uh [ __ ]
incense over there that's got it in so
if you actually wanted to adequately
assess the impact of these things though
like again how impactful are they at the
end of the day like even things like
your lifestyle your exercise regimen all
super impactful above and beyond the
Sleep the diet the exposure to all these
toxins Etc
doing blood work I think is absolutely
warranted to have a baseline as early as
possible where it's you know your Peak
hormone output you know 21 25 years old
have some sort of Baseline profile that
is comprehensive so then if something
goes awry you can then go back and
identify where there are deficiencies
and balances Etc what went wrong and why
so some of these exposures to whatever
it is that's detrimental to testosterone
or lackluster fill in the blank
if you change that you could then get
blood work done to assess is my
gonadotropin output now sufficient
compared to before if it was sub-optimal
you can see pretty clearly like rather
than being speculative about
does this help maybe I should totally
change this area of my life because it
might be sub-optimal like there are some
things that might be you don't want to
do that you think are going to be
conducive to better hormones and maybe
it has no impact whatsoever and at that
point you could go get a basic
testosterone test marichealth.com
you could go there that would be that
would be a worthwhile place to go I'll
do your address for you all right thanks
bro I appreciate it what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]